this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon hey
crazies welcome to part three of our
series on electrodynamics in part two I
made the following comments we usually
have a bunch of charges moving together
in something we call a current hmm I
think that deserves a little more
attention if you've been watching this
channel for a while you know that
language is tricky business especially
in science you have to be careful with
your word choices the word current is
usually used to describe a fluid like
water moving continuously in a certain
direction but discharge actually moves
like water we certainly thought it did
when we gave it that name but to answer
this question we need to delve a little
deeper than usual into materials first
materials are made of atoms a bunch of
protons and neutrons surrounded by a
cloud of electrons those electrons are
the lighter looser particles so they do
the moving in materials second we like
to divide materials into two categories
conductors and insulators a conductor is
a material that freely allows the flow
of charge an insulator is a material
that does not allow the flow of charge
either type of material can become
charged what matters is whether or not
the charge can move once it's there
category alert category alert category
alert okay okay I'll mention it quick
disclaimer always be cautious of
categories they give us these little
bite-sized pieces our limited brains are
capable of understanding but reality
consistently resists that kind of
simplicity like most things materials
fall in a spectrum conductors on one end
and insulators on the other no material
is a perfect example of either type but
the three best conductors are silver
copper and gold in that order it's no
coincidence that those all fall in the
same chemical group they each have one
very loose electron on their
our edges that alone doesn't make them a
good conductor though a material isn't
made of one atom it's made of a bunch of
them we need to see how those atoms work
together atoms are always bonded by
their electrons in metals like copper
the electrons tend to form one big cloud
for the entire material so this really
comes down to the quantum states of the
electrons in the material specifically
the energy levels in a single atom
electrons can be in a variety of energy
levels but when atoms are together in
materials those levels are separated
into bands a conduction band and valence
band the lower energy levels don't
matter because they're buried
what separates conductors from
insulators is how much energy it takes
for an electron to jump from the valence
band to the conduction band for
insulators like glass the gap is really
big in semiconductors like Silicon the
gap is small in conductors like copper
there is no gap valence electrons are
conduction electrons that's what makes
them so conductive there are already
electrons in the conduction band ready
to go if they get a reason to move
through the material they'll do it
but is that how water moves well kind of
we want to be careful with our
comparison here the analog for charge is
the water those are normal scale things
the analog for a single electron is a
water molecule they're microscopic
things we need to keep those two things
separate let's consider water first say
you've got a long pipe with some water
at rest inside the water molecules look
like this moving around randomly
if the water begins to move through the
pipe the molecules move to because
they're what make up the water they
still have the random motion but they
now also have forward motion a similar
thing happens with the charge and a
copper wire that wire is full of
conducting electrons just like the pipe
was full of water individual electrons
are conducting around the copper
randomly if we connect a power source
though it'll acts like a pump the
electrons will still have the random
motion but also some forward motion
except electrons a qualm particle so we
don't know where they are exactly
ah you different let me get away with
anything nope okay so according to
quantum mechanics if we know the energy
of the electrons we don't really know
their position those measurements are
mutually exclusive we don't really know
where individual electrons are in this
wire but we do know the whole collection
of them is drifting forward in fact
there's something called drift velocity
which tells us how fast that drift is
and it's a lot slower than you might
think
in this copper wire it's only about an
inch and a half per hour that's 4
centimeters per hour wait a minute
then how come this flashlight turns on
instantly because changes in the
electric field transfer at the speed of
light a flashlight is pretty simple a
couple of batteries a light bulb and a
switch it could easily take an hour for
the charge to get from the battery to
the light bulb but once the switch is
flipped the battery's electric field
travels across the circuit at the speed
of light and all the charge in all the
conductor's moves it nearly the same
time how cool is that anyway charge
moves a lot slower in a wire than water
does through a pipe but that's okay
electric current isn't about speed it's
measured as the amount of charge over
time not distance over time there's a
lot of charge in a wire so a high
current doesn't actually need to move
that fast what does the charge move
through the entire volume of the wire
sure well at least when the current is
direct now all right one more thing
there are two different ways charge can
flow direct current or DC which is a
steady flow in one direction and
alternating current or AC which is a
continuously changing flow that goes
back and forth can't you do either of
those with water - well yeah but but
there's something hiding in the details
the inside edge of the pipe can put drag
on the water so it moves more freely
near the center for electric current in
a wire it's the other way around the
behavior of the atoms in the center
restricts the number of electrons that
can flow so they actually move more
freely near the edge in DC electrons
flow through the entire volume in spite
of this
for a see the flow is mostly limited to
the outer edges it's called the skin
effect what was the original question
again discharge flow like water right
yeah kind of if you're not concerned
with where the moving charged particles
actually are in the material then a
water flow is a good analogy for
electric currents so good in fact it has
a name the hydraulic analogy there's a
hydraulic equivalent for every circuit
component you could imagine it's kind of
fascinating
so got any more questions about electric
current please ask in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to patreon
patrons like Kenny Holmes who helped
keep the show going with their generous
support don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy by far the most common
comment from the magnet video was what
about neodymium magnets neodymium is an
element yes it is but neodymium magnets
are not an element they're neodymium to
iron 14 boron they're actually a
molecule not an element anyway thanks
for watching